over the last several years hundreds of
large skill murals have appeared in
cities and towns all over the world
wildly colorful and beautifully painted
they've mostly shown up in troubled and
neglected communities but the point of
the art isn't so much to transform the
landscape it's to change the lives of
the painters
brook silva-braga is here with that
story Brooke good morning good morning
guys well this all started when two
american artists began sharing their
paint with some kids they meant youth
living in some very difficult situations
and what they experienced when they did
that convinced both of them to take
their art careers in a very different
direction so we actually are going to be
building a giant bird that is going to
be a giant percussive sculpture max
Freder and Joel Burge nerve have
organized 400 of these murals now
painting with refugee children from
Syria hospital patients in Mexico Street
kids from India and whether the young
painters know it or not the point of the
projects isn't really to brighten up the
walls
what are your paying although they do
that too it's about people having the
power and the opportunity to tell their
own story and to shape their own
narrative other people Society is saying
we're gonna label you we're gonna give
you an identity and it's a really
negative one and you being able to take
that back and actually I'm going to
create my own identity and my own story
and that's my resident love because some
people don't get love and affection
this mural in New York City was a canvas
for special needs students from the
Manhattan School of career development
as well as high schoolers from the
Harvey Milk School which serves LGBT
students and my idea was the rice in
Phoenix each project starts with a
meeting to work up themes and sketch out
ideas
laverne is a sophomore at Harvey Milk
the goal was
paint something that sort of represents
who you are and your dreams and what's
the dream you tried to put on the wall
well I'm transgender and so my dream is
to have the body that represents my
gender so I drew a naked woman my dream
is to sort of be seen for who I am the
idea for the murals started nine years
ago pretty much by accident when Joel
was living in a favela in Rio de Janeiro
Brazil during that time I started to
work with the youth there and started to
create murals with them and I thought
hmm this is something that actually
works I can actually use my skills as a
counselor that I've developed and my
skills as an artist and kind of bring
those two together and it really fits so
deokee at about that same time max
started doing something similar with
Maori youth who'd been in prison in New
Zealand then really the arts are
catalysts to talk about the most
important issues in their lives the two
of them joined up and formed a nonprofit
called art Ellucian a few hundred murals
later the idea is getting attention and
now a big check from Gucci through there
chime for change campaign at first it
wasn't like that
it took years for us to be able to
convince people to that this matters why
they sign on
I think people signed on because they
realized this is a unique innovative
approaches to problems that that other
kinds of solutions have not been able to
solve but the problems will not be
easily solved in places like the refugee
camps of Cox's Bazar in Bangladesh where
more than half a million wrote Inga have
fled from Myanmar these are kids with
real serious problems with great respect
to the work you're doing why worry about
art art is being used as a tool you know
you have international organizations
providing food and health care and a
roof over people's heads and those
things are of course vital and people
need those but then you take a step back
and you say okay what about the trauma
what about the conflicts and so dealing
with that is a much more complicated
issue right these are issues of mental
health and when you put the brush in
their hands what was the story they
wanted to tell one of the stories that
they wanted to tell was a story about a
family of elephants
and the family of elephants was carrying
their homes over the naff River which is
the river that divides Myanmar and
Bangladesh and that as they cross the
river there's a rooster that was there
to greet them talking about the
relationship between the Bengali people
and the Rohingya people a story of being
welcome yeah acceptance was a theme in
New York too on the wall and at the
unveiling ceremony where the principal
of the Harvey Milk school conceded she
initially worried the project would
waste class time
this experience has truly been
transformative and magical Laverne and
the others signed their names to the
wall and reveled in what they've made
and when you look at her what do you
think I see hope when I look at her
because it's sort of my future for me
being trans sometimes I feel like I not
seen the way I want to be seen and with
art you have all the control in the
world to just sort of present yourself
the way you want to max and Joel are
actually in Lebanon right now in a key
part of their mission especially for
these international projects is to train
local artists to work with the children
so for example at that row hinga camp in
Bangladesh the painting of the murals
has continued now for months under the
guidance of local artists who can work
with the kids and it's also a chance for
those artists to be artists it's amazing
how powerful these kind of projects
alright know they've done a lot of like
this in Philadelphia they have a mural
program so many murals and where they
yeah where they involve the communities
and and when you bring the community in
and they everybody creates something
together there's a sense of ownership
and it's incredibly explosive in
community as well you know in any school
there's tension between kids and one of
the students we spoke to said you know
this is the one time where we don't seem
to be fighting and bickering and worried
about the little things that normally
get in the way of the school day and
gorgeous also works amazing works great
too
brook silva-braga thank you very much